I'm often drawn to
very generic materials
as a starting
point for my work I
think because they
have a very easy entry
point things feel immediately
identifiable in some way.
There's a material resonance.
I think that people feel
that they understand
what it is and in a way that
easy entry then I feel opens up
the possibility of
metaphor is kind
of expanding out from them.
The first time I started
using the materials
that are in this exhibition, the
pieces that look like figures.
I call these forms
slumps because they're
sort of these
figurative forms that
depend on a hard
structure of some kind
to support them and armature.
And their way of thinking about
the relation between the body
and the support
systems that hold up
the body as a kind of
co-dependent relationship.
And I was particularly
interested in foam
as the base material
for these slumps
because it is a material that's
used it's a cheap bed material.
The other material in
this exhibition of course
is are the emergency blankets.
They are of course,
materials that
are used to keep people warm.
It has a protective
element to it.
But when stretched,
it also turns
into a kind of two way mirror.
I'm interested in
that and how as people
walk in front of and
behind this vertical plane,
they are hidden and
revealed from each other.
They are reflected
again into the space
and sometimes into each other
because it's a two way mirror
And it also presents
the sculpture
through reflection
in this rounded form.
So there are a variety of
formal and conceptual reasons
that are always working
together in my material choices.
And I'm always thinking
about these different layers
of the space vertically.
And in this exhibition, there
are hanging water bottles
that are sort of at mid-level.
They're kind of at eye level.
There are these, I think of
them as extensions of the body.
They're water
bottles so they are
used to carry water
which you drink
to replenish your own water.
But I've also been
interested in how
day laborers and people
who, again don't have space,
don't have a bathroom
to go to often will use
that same bottle to urinate in.
And so it becomes this
receptacle for bodily fluids
as well.
And so in a way,
it's a size of a head
and it hangs at head height.
So I think of them as
again bodily at the height
of a person standing.
And then finally, these
exit signs or pieces
that are quite high up on
the wall and force people
to look up.
They're also hung in a way
where from any given point,
you can at best see one
side of an exit sign
and so you have to move through
the space to see the two
words on any given sign.
And so the movement
of the viewer
is an important
part of the piece
things are hidden and revealed
as you walk through the space.
In this current show
and in previous shows,
I used text in
different ways here.
It's through these what
I think of as two word
poems in a way, these
exit signs that I think
help people
contextualize the work,
gives people anchors through
which to enter the work
rather than provide a
descriptive entry point.
So for example, let's see.
Grave/ Grove, the title
of the exhibition,
which is also an exit sign
in the exhibition was a way
of thinking about this moment
that we're living through,
the pandemic as a moment that
is of course one that reminds us
of our mortality.
We're confronted
constantly with death.
But last spring,
there was this moment
when the seasons changed
in New York and plants
started to grow out
of the sidewalk cracks
and there was something
quite beautiful
about this rebirth
within a city.
A rebirth not so much of the
people but of this other life
form these plants
and particularly
plants that are not
considered valuable to humans
that are considered weeds.
But that irrespective of our
desire to have them around,
they thrive and they
come back every year.